what makes you great at story oh great
that's a good question what makes me
great at story okay so I think what
makes me great a story is that I
understand story and there's a
difference between having an idea and
having a story and I think a lot of
people get stuck in the idea phase which
basically means you have an element to a
story like you might have a great
character you might have a great
situation for you to put for you to put
them in there might be a great world
that has that you've started to
originate but until you have every
single one of those elements you don't
yet have a story so me understanding
what it takes to have a story helps me
to help writers get to the place where
they have a full story and so I'm able
to look at what they have and say okay
so you've got a great idea but now how
do we make that into a story how do we
make how do we give this character some
depth and then give them an actual goal
so that they can have something to do
during their story or how do we have
this goal and give a character who would
be great at actually making the goal
happen or the total opposite they could
never make that goal happen so now their
journey is gonna be getting to a place
of actually being able to reach that
goal so I'm always looking into it to
see what elements do you have what
elements do you need and how can we
really flesh out what your full story is
and is that because sometimes they're
actually writing a story that's loosely
based on them or no it is sometimes
sometimes I I have dealt with a lot of
writers who are writing something that
is based on truth and it's really easy
to get stuck in that and that's because
when you're stuck in truth you're stuck
in trying to tell the truth and I always
say to them go look at the actual films
that are based on true stories and read
that line underneath based on a true
story right which means that you can't
get hung up in what actually happened
because in most of our lives everyday is
not entertaining even if you look at
reality television right they have their
cameras there for 12 hours a day and
they're filming but you at home are not
watching 12 hours of them filming
someone because there's not enough
there's not enough entertaining stuff
happening so the producers are going to
take all of that footage
and then go home and craft a story which
is why you may then have people dressed
in one way having a conversation in the
next five minutes they're in another
place having that same conversation but
we don't know those conversations could
have been months apart but they built
the story for us because we have to
understand what it is that we're
following so the same thing is true when
it's in scripted form just because it's
based on true story doesn't mean it's
dramatic enough doesn't mean it's
entertaining enough so we have to figure
out what's the story that you're
actually trying to tell like what's the
root thing and then let's put all the
elements to it regardless to whether
it's the truth and then let's tell the
story but I think in general writing is
one of those things that a lot of people
don't understand has a skill to it has a
structure to it so people wake up and
say I want to be a writer
because I have this great idea and I
give the example of if I were a 35 year
old man who had never played football a
day in my life never and then I woke up
one day and said I'm gonna go walk into
an NFL team people would look at me like
I was insane so I give that same look
when people just wake up and say I'm a
writer because I have an idea it's like
you still got to go build that muscle
you still gotta go go to practice write
by writing and writing and writing
before you can get to a place where you
can assume that you're gonna have like a
Shonda Rhimes kind of script right just
like I'm not gonna wake up one day and
just be able to be in the NFL so I think
people kind of get stuck in that place
because it's creative and so they think
we're there no rules
anybody can be creative yes anybody can
be creative but that doesn't necessarily
mean that you have all the elements that
you need for a story and it's a great
point and you know you talked about you
know based on a true story or whatever
based on it's funny that you mentioned
that because there's at least two films
right now great films but when I went
back and read and did some research on
the stories that they were based on some
very major parts were left out mm-hmm
and I was talking to David about him
like why would they leave this out I
think you were saying that it's because
maybe just didn't finish the story
didn't fit into the story and the story
has to be king
the writer cannot be pushing a narrative
even though sometimes you will watch
things and obviously the writers saying
this is what I'm trying to say right but
some of the best
art is giving you all of the information
and let letting you decide what they're
trying to say or are you getting lost in
well is it this or is it that and you
having to come up with your own decision
about it
versus the writer just sending you to it
so I often tell people the characters
have to be making decisions based on who
they are not based on who you are right
so you may need for your character to
get from A to B and so you're saying
well I'm gonna have them do it this way
but would that character do it that way
or are you just forcing them into doing
something because you need to get them
to the other end so I'm hoping that
that's the reason that they didn't put
it in there just didn't work into the
you know to the arc of the story and so
if it was gonna push the story in a
different direction or show you a
different side of the person that you
didn't want them to see you know what I
mean because if you establish a
character as being one way and then they
act in a way that's not within those
bounds you now have raised a question
for your audience so now your audience
is going to be thinking for the rest of
the film well what was that well what
does that mean and how does that
influence blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and
if it literally doesn't influence
anything else and the character just
absent mindedly acted without on the
outside of themselves that question
never leaves and now we might leave the
theater going there was just something
about it you know like we can't maybe we
can't put our finger on it some people
might be able to say well it's because
they did this and that's why it doesn't
make any sense to me most people won't
really be able to put their finger on it
but they'll be thinking to themselves
there's something there that I just
didn't understand and it's because that
character made a decision outside of
what you told us he or she was so
sometimes it's best to leave those
things out unless you are purposefully
showing me that so I gave an example to
I'm teaching an online class right now
and I gave an example to a student and
it said if there's a woman who is
ex-military and she is fighting men like
physically fighting right and she fights
one she fights two she fights three she
fights for but when five comes she
freaks she freezes and she runs then
that tells me there's something there
some things going on with this
particular guy she just fought four
other guys
why didn't she fight him now if it never
comes back so I understand why she
didn't fight
I'm gonna have that question for the
rest of the time I'm gonna wonder what
that was and so that might have been the
first breadcrumb to teach us something
between them something from her past
something about something about him made
her freeze and flee instead of fight so
everything within the film has to be
working towards you know that story and
if it's not then just leave it out and
that and you're right that was it was
two different films and that and that
was it it did it made the character look
different
great point okay excellent
you